I'm standing here by the Google Corkboard
Server Rack. This server rack was built in
1999 by Google employees simply because you
could not buy the computers required to achieve
the scale, reliability, and performance that Google
required. Each row here, has eight hard drives
on it, and four complete PCs. And there is a cork mat, to shield the electronics
from the metal frame that carries the row up.
That's why it was called the Google Corkboard Server
Rack. When your application runs on the Google Cloud
platform, you can be sure it runs on the
latest and best hardware. Well, perhaps not this version
from 1999. But the latest version that we built.
So, in this lesson we're going to cover the heavy
duty stuff. We'll start it off by looking at memcash,
a great way to optimize the performance of your application, then we'll
look at background jobs. In the form of push queues, pull queues,
and cron jobs and we'll wrap it up by looking at some
of the scaling and tuning parameters for appendium. Let's get started, shall we?